the the monetary aspect of being a child
actor you know we have to put some of it
into a trust but then others you know
like wow we got a car
and it has the license plate says 4 mpg
oh well thank you wait a minute i can't
drive it i can't drive it but thank you
that's my car yeah but they sucked a lot
of money away from you and i got to
think that
you know being on a show you probably
didn't get paid that much when you're
unsaved by the bell no
i think at the height of it again i
don't know the finances because i wasn't
involved at that time but i think at the
height of it we are getting paid maybe
five thousand a week for a show five
thousand a week on a show now you think
that's a lot of money five thousand
dollars a week well you got agents and
taxes and you're walking out of there
with two grand a week on a show that's a
hit show that people are what kids are
watching all across the world
and you're making five thousand dollars
an episode i think when people assume
that when you're on tv they assume
you're making millions of dollars
but that's not where you're making your
bucks
no it's not where you're making their
bucks and then you think like well he
went to syndication
syndication for us i get syndication
checks i mean i i giggle about it
because somebody had to print that on a
jet but it's like 13 cents
10 cents for you know
hundreds of shows being
shown it it's run its course
jesus so no i don't i don't make it and
then you would think oh well what about
merchandise well we got screwed out of
that too we don't get any money through
merchandise um
you know we don't we don't get much so
uh when you see our names as producers
on uh on the the peacock show it's a
nice it's a nice
way for us to be a part of the show
again right and we we have always from
day one
um well i shouldn't say from day one i'd
say there was a period there where we
were all struggling to break free of
that you know the the sort of stigma
attached to say by the bell but for the
most part we've all been very positive
about our experiences with the with that
uh show it's also amazing that you've um
are you guys all still friends mostly
sure yeah i think so
and you know i read and you know of
course this is old news but said you
actually dated three of your co-stars
but you're probably a kid when that
happened
yeah no i mean it all happened in the
span of the show none of us dated after
the show was cancelled
and so there was no bad blood about that
there was like who was the one that you
think you crushed on the hardest that
like it wasn't just dating like you
thought you were in love with
uh
[Applause]
i i i mean i don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings so i i think i can
say that
i i probably didn't have the biggest
crush
on tiffany only because
tiffany and i had a different
relationship her and i were very
uh we're almost like siblings in a way i
know that's hard for people who watch
the show it's like zach and kelly were
siblings but that's
we really had a a closeness
that that's what that closeness
translated into and it's still to this
day she's probably the closest one that
i that
that i'm that i have a relationship with
now
wow
yeah her and i you know probably
see each other
more than anyone else and
partly because i really like her husband
brady uh
he's just he's just an amazing dude yeah
and they have good kids and and you know
i i really like her and i i
yeah i like her family and stuff like i
like everyone's but tiffany and i always
had this closeness but it was it
translated into
being siblings and then when we kind of
dated it was just awkward it was weird
it didn't feel as great as like the
relationship we had before right
you